teamwork is your friend guys should all  be prioritizing and incentivizing  accountability key benchmarks lb putts  and optimizing synergy  our sales are down due to unsuccessful  cold calls that we've been making and we  need to be more successful making those  cold calls that are going to push our  domestic sales until we hit our  designated and ratio what do you want  [Music]  what's important is that you trust your  team leaders and don't be afraid to  speak your mind that said do whatever  they say  and don't ask questions really you're  just gonna want to rein in your ideas  and do what you're told  hey anybody have any thing to say out  loud to somebody else I think it's gonna  be all about figuring out how to team  there's no I in team  otherwise it would be T I'm with  teamwork and a bit of communication we  can really kill it in the next quarter  and not have to go into overtime  [Music]  [Music]  unfinished business  [Applause]  belated our